UNDER THE AGE OF 45.
SHOULD THAT STATE STILL BE
LOCKED DOWN?
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE"
INVESTIGATES.
BUT FIRST, THE KIDS AREN’T ALL
RIGHT.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE"."
ABOUT THREE QUARTERS OF THE
WORLD’S SCHOOLCHILDREN ARE NOT
IN SCHOOL, AND THEY ARE NOT
THERE BECAUSE OF COVID-19.
IT AFFECTS ABOUT 1.5 BILLION
CHILDREN AND YOUNG PEOPLE.
I SEARCHED, AND I CAN’T FIND ANY
EXAMPLE OF THIS EVER HAVING
HAPPENED ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE
MODERN WORLD, NOT IN HISTORY.
NOW, FEW DISAGREE THAT PROLONGED
ABSENCE FROM THE CLASSROOM HAS
PROFOUND IMPLICATIONS FOR
CHILDREN’S WELL-BEING.
THERE DEVELOPMENT, AND THEIR
KNOWLEDGE RETENTION.
BLACK FRIDAY, ONE OF THE MOST
RENOWNED PEDIATRIC
SPECIALISTS IN THE WORLD,
EXPRESSED HIS CONCERN ON THE
SHOW ABOUT THE HARM THIS IS
CAUSING.
>> WE KNOW FROM STUDIES NOW OUT
OF CHINA THAT DEPRESSION RATES
IN KIDS WHO HAVE BEEN LOCKED
DOWN ARE UP 20 TO 30%.
WE KNOW THAT CHILDREN FROM LOW
INCOME FAMILIES IN PARTICULAR
FOR BEING HOMESCHOOLED, THEY ARE
NOT GETTING AN ADEQUATE
EDUCATION, BECAUSE THEIR PARENTS
ARE WORKING, BECAUSE THEY DON’T
HAVE HIGH-SPEED INTERNET, AND
THOSE KIDS ARE FALLING FURTHER
AND FURTHER BEHIND.
>> Laura: AT RISK KIDS ARE
ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE, CERTAINLY
THAT MAKES SENSE.
ALMOST ALL MOMS WITH WHOM I
SPEAK ARE FRUSTRATED, AND
THEY’RE FRANKLY FRIGHTENED THAT
THESE CLOSERS ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE INDEFINITELY.
WHETHER PARENTS WORK OUTSIDE OR
INSIDE THE HOME OR THEY ARE
STAY-AT-HOME PARENTS, MOST ARE
NOT WELL-SUITED TO BE TEACHING
AN ARRAY OF SUBJECTS, ESPECIALLY
IF THEY HAVE MULTIPLE CHILDREN.
BY THE WAY, THE TEACHERS DON’T
SEEM ALL THAT THRILLED, EITHER.
TO SPEAK ALL OF MY KIDS IN MY
CLASSROOM ARE ALL RELAXING,
TALKING, MOVEMENT, BUSYNESS, AND
I’VE GONE FROM THAT TO A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT THING WHERE I AM AND
I.T. PERSON LOOKING AT A SCREEN
ALL DAY JUST TRYING TO HELP
PARENTS WITH TECH ISSUES ALL DAY
LONG.
>> Laura: OKAY, I’VE BEEN
THERE, GUILTY AS CHARGED, TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT THE TECH ISSUES.
DIGITAL LEARNING, DISTANCE
LEARNING, ONLINE CLASSES, THEY
HAVE A PLACE AND THEY MAY WORK
AS A SUPPLEMENT OR SHORT PERIODS
OF TIME, BUT IT ALL GETS OLD
FAST, AND IT LEADS, IN SOME
CASES, TO A FEELING OF
ISOLATION, AND IT JUST DOESN’T
ENGAGE PEOPLE LIKE IN PERSON
LEARNING.
YET, 192 COUNTRIES PULLED KIDS
OUT OF SCHOOL, AND THESE
DECISIONS WERE BASED NOT SO MUCH
ON SCIENCE, BUT OUT OF AN
ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION.
YOU REALLY CAN’T BLAME PEOPLE.
EVERYONE IS WORRIED, FREAKING
OUT, DON’T WANT ANYTHING TO
HAPPEN TO THEIR KIDS.
SO WHAT DO WE KNOW NOW ABOUT THE
HEALTH RISKS TO CHILDREN AND TWO
ADULTS IF THEY RETURN TO SCHOOL?
WELL, WE KNOW NOW THAT
OVERWHELMINGLY, CHILDREN DO NOT
GET SERIOUSLY ILL FROM COVID,
THANK GOODNESS.
MOST TESTING POSITIVE OR TOTALLY
ASYMPTOMATIC.
RECENTLY, HEALTH OFFICIALS ARE
REPORTING INSTANCES, THOUGH, OF
AN INFLAMMATORY REACTION IN KIDS
THAT COULD BE COVID-RELATED,
ALTHOUGH IT IS ALSO RARELY
FATAL.
THE REAL DEBATE RIGHT NOW
SURROUNDS HOW MUCH, IF AT ALL,
CHILDREN SPREAD THE VIRUS TO
ADULTS.
THE IDEA THAT THEY ARE SILENT
SUPER-SPREADER’S -- THAT SOUNDED
SUPER SCARY SOME WEEKS AGO --
BUT THAT BASICALLY HAS BEEN
DEBUNKED.
MORE RESEARCH IS NEEDED, YET WE
REGARD THE SCHOOL ISSUE, MAYBE
WE START THINKING ABOUT IT THIS
WAY, A COMPARISON TO INFLUENZA
MIGHT BE ILLUSTRATIVE.
ACCORDING TO THE CDC’S NUMBERS,
WHICH IS ALL WE HAVE TO GO BY,
THIS PAST FLU SEASON WAS A VERY
BAD ONE FOR CHILDREN.
WHILE ONLY A HANDFUL OF CHILDREN
DIED FROM COVID NATIONWIDE AS
OF MAY 9TH, THE CDC REPORTED 174
PEDIATRIC FLU DEATHS THIS SEASON
SEASON.
IN ADDITION, WE HAD 18 MILLION
MEDICAL VISITS AND 410,000
HOSPITALIZATIONS DUE TO THE
INFLUENCE OF THE SEASON.
AGAIN, ACCORDING TO THE CDC.
ON ITS WEBSITE, THE CDC
ESTIMATES BETWEEN -- THIS IS
CURIOUS -- 24,062,000
PRELIMINARY FLU DEATHS.
THAT’S QUITE A RANGE.
COMPLICATED, I GUESS, TO GET THE
STATES TURNING IN ALL OF THEIR
DATA, BUT COULD BE AS MANY AS
62,000.
WHY DIDN’T WE HEAR ABOUT THE FLU
VIS-A-VIS KIDS IN SCHOOL.
EVEN WITH A DOUBLE BARREL OF
THREATS OF INFLUENZA A AND
INFLUENZA B, WHICH KIDS WERE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO THE SEASON, AND
THE FACT IT’S HIGHLY CONTAGIOUS
AMONG CLASSMATES, WE HAD NO WHY
SKILL SCHOOL CLOSERS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
I DIDN’T EVEN HEAR ANYONE
SUGGESTING THEM.
EVEN DURING THE SWINE FLU
EPIDEMIC, ONLY ABOUT 726 OF THE
MORE THAN 131,000 K-12 SCHOOLS
IN THE COUNTRY SHUTDOWN.
I’M NOT SAYING COVID-19, BY THE
WAY, IS LIKE THE FLU.
IT IS NOT.
BUT WHAT I AM SAYING IS FAR MORE
CHILDREN DIED OF INFLUENZA THIS
YEAR, THAT IT’S HIGHLY
CONTAGIOUS AMONG THEM, YET NO
ONE SERIOUSLY CONSIDERED KEEPING
MOST OF OUR NATION’S
SCHOOLCHILDREN AT HOME BECAUSE
OF THE DANGER.
NOW, LAST MONTH, A REVIEW WAS
PUBLISHED OF PAST CORONAVIRUS
STUDIES, AND IT SUGGESTS THAT
CLOSING SCHOOLS MAY ONLY HAVE A
MINOR ROLE IN SUPPRESSING
COVID-19.
YOU LOOK AT THE DATA FROM SARS
AND THAT OUTBREAK IN MAINLAND
CHINA, HONG KONG, AND SINGAPORE,
AND IT SUGGESTS SCHOOL
TRANSMISSIONS PLAYED NO
SUBSTANTIAL ROLE IN THE
OUTBREAK.
AND THAT SCHOOL CLOSURES AND
OTHER ACTIVITIES, SUCH AS SCHOOL
TEMPERATURE MONITORING, DID NOT
CONTRIBUTE TO THE CONTROL OF
INFECTIOUS TRANSMISSION.
I GUESS WE WILL SEE HOW IT GOES
WITH COVID-19, BUT CERTAINLY
WORTH NOTING THAT.
NOW, IN SWEDEN, SCHOOLCHILDREN
THERE WERE NEVER PULLED FROM
SCHOOLS, AND MEANWHILE, THE
GUARDIAN REPORTS THAT REOPENING
SCHOOLS IN 22 EUROPEAN COUNTRIES
HAS NOT LED TO
ANY SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
CORONAVIRUS INFECTIONS AMONG
CHILDREN, AMONG PARENTS, OR
STAFF.
NOW, THERE WAS A THING IN
FRANCE, 70 PEOPLE IN AN
OUTBREAK, BUT OUT OF A HUGE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE BACK IN SCHOOL,
THEY HAVE A HANDLE ON THAT.
TODAY, I WENT ON A TWO HOUR BIKE
RIDE THROUGH D.C. WITH MY
11-YEAR-OLD, WENT THROUGH THE
WOODS, WENT THROUGH PARTS OF THE
CITY, AND ALL FOUR OF US GO ON
THESE LONG WALKS IN THE WOODS,
MOST MORNINGS.
MY KIDS AND I.
THAT’S BEEN A TREAT FOR ME.
AND FOR THEM, USUALLY, ALTHOUGH
SOMETIMES THEY ROLL THEIR EYES
AT ME, BUT THAT’S JUST THE WAY
IT GOES.
THESE ARE MEMORIES I CHERISH
BECAUSE THEY ARE HOME FROM
SCHOOL, WE CAN DO THAT.
BUT I HAVE TO SAY I’M REALLY
WORRIED ABOUT HOW MUCH THEY
REALLY LEARNED THIS SEMESTER.
EVEN HOW GREAT THEIR TEACHERS
ARE, IT’S STILL NOT THE SAME,
AND I SEE HOW MUCH THEY MISS
THEIR FRIENDS AND THEIR
TEACHERS, AND THE ADMINISTRATORS
AT THEIR SCHOOLS.
I’M ALSO THINKING -- AND WE PRAY
FOR THIS EVERY NIGHT -- ABOUT
THE LESS FORTUNATE AMONG US.
THEY DON’T HAVE ANY HELP, THEY
DON’T HAVE THE LUXURY OF
VENTURING INTO NATURE EVERY DAY,
PERHAPS.
AND WHAT ABOUT THE FRONT-LINE
WORKERS?
THEY CAN’T FIND CHILD CARE OR
SOMEONE TO SUPPLEMENT THE
TEACHING OF THEIR KIDS.
WHAT HAPPENS IF UNEMPLOYED
PEOPLE IN THE FALL FIND JOBS --
WE HOPE THEY DO -- YET THEIR
KIDS SCHOOLS SAY "SORRY, THEY
ARE NOT COMING BACK?"
WE NEED TO GET CREATIVE AND NOT
ABANDON CLASSROOM LEARNING,
CERTAINLY SINCE WE DON’T HAVE
ANY REAL DATA TO BACK THIS UP.
NOW, CHECK THIS OUT.
CAMBRIDGE UNIVERSITY HAS
BASICALLY GIVEN UP, AND THEY’VE
ANNOUNCED THEY ARE NOT OPENING
UNTIL I THINK THE SUMMER OF
2021, AT THIS POINT.
BUT WE CAN BE SMARTER, AND R.
NOTRE DAME JUST ANNOUNCED THAT
ITS OPENING IN THE FALL BUT THEY
ARE GOING TO END THEIR SEMESTER
A LITTLE EARLY AND KILL THE FALL
BREAK.
I DON’T KNOW WHY THEY HAVE THE
FALL BREAK ANYWAY THERE, BUT
THEY ARE KILLING THAT IN CASE
THERE IS A SECOND WAVE.
THEY ARE MODERATING, BUT GETTING
PEOPLE BACK.
KIDS NEED SCHOOL AT ALL AGES.
WE CAN PROTECT THEIR HEALTH, AND
WE CAN PROTECT THEIR MINDS.
WE CAN USE OUR INNOVATION, AND
WE CAN USE OUR COMMON SENSE.